[Music]
the ocean a body of unparalleled beauty
and on World Oceans Day we recognize
this vast ecosystem home to crustaceans
sea stars
plate cephalopods the elusive C square
and of course the sea sponge but it's up
to us to come together
and preserve this peaceful and delicate
world
so for World Oceans Day do your part to
keep our oceans clean and protect your
home of spongebob and Gary and all sea
creatures
don't miss the spongebob movie sponge
all around
coming soon to cinemas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
carry fan mail that
[Music]
summer the search begins friends don't
let friends to a dangerous quest
with all new faces
hello call me sage Goodman eight out of
sage I am a sage so it works out pretty
well
I'm Patrick my name means toaster in
Celtic pretty sure it doesn't the most
amazing places look wouldn't worry about
us losing
[Music]
7/7 starts with an L weird sponge on the
run oh I love your sense of irony
Patrick thank you I love my sense of
irony too
[Music]